bah pour moi et pour l'équipe du bureau
de transport va nous c'est globalement
positif parce qu'on a eu aucun souci
m'ont parfois des petits projets de
circulation dus aux compétitions ou une
sortie compétition mais mise à part sa
ble ment la mouvement très positif très
sympa parce qu'on a pu rencontrer ben
plein de personnes venant notamment de
l'étranger qui en a pu discuter échanger
aussi bien que l'équipe de france qu'on
a pu applaudir encourager mais de belles
rencontres des discussions sympathique
aussi bien enfin aussi bien entre 6h du
matin que 23 heures le soir et
effectivement les gens font voir fois un
petit peu près c'est donc pas forcément
le temps d'en discuter mais la plupart
du temps on arrive à échanger de façon
agréable